black hole Stars may have been the
largest stars that ever existed they
burned brighter than galaxies and were
larger than any Star today or that could
ever exist in the future but besides
their scale what makes them special and
weird is that deep inside they were
occupied by a cosmic parasite an
endlessly hungry black hole how is that
even possible
foreign
[Music]
black hole Stars take the weirdness of
black holes and go beyond to break
everything we know about how stars form
and grow they were only possible during
a short window of time in the early
universe but if they existed they would
solve one of the largest mysteries of
cosmology
black hole stars were excessive anywhere
you look at them the most massive stars
today may have about 300 solar masses a
black hole Star had up to 10 million
solar masses of nearly pure hydrogen
let's take a moment to look at what this
means visually
the sun wesen Al pegasi the largest star
and finally the black hole star
its scale is beyond words
over 800 000 times wider than our sun
380 times larger than the largest star
we know today
and Far Below its surface is a black
hole growing rapidly as it devours
billions upon billions of tons of matter
per second
normally Stars Are Born from gigantic
clouds collections of thousands or
millions of solar masses of mostly
hydrogen in these clouds Mata starts to
accumulate around the densest spots
inside
as these spots get denser their
gravitational pull intensifies and they
grow faster
eventually they generate so much heat
and pressure that they ignite Fusion
reactions and a new star is born
but this puts a limit on their size
nuclear fusion releases enough radiation
energy that the surrounding gas cloud is
blown away the new baby star can't
gather more mass
from now on the star is living on the
edge between two forces gravity pulling
in trying to squash the star and
radiation created by Fusion pushing
outwards trying to blow the star apart
after millions or billions of years the
core runs out of fuel and the balance
breaks destroying the star
but black hole stars were very very
different
the beasts of the other universe
few hundred million years after the big
bang when the universe was much smaller
all the matter in existence was much
more concentrated
the universe was much denser and hotter
Dark Matter was a dominant player
forming giant structures called Dark
Matter halos
these dark matter Halos were so massive
that they pulled in and concentrated
unimaginably gigantic amounts of
hydrogen gas becoming the birthplaces of
the first stars and galaxies
epic clouds of hydrogen fought some as
massive as 100 Million Suns more than
the mass of small galaxies in this
unique environment that will never exist
again the enormous gravitational pull of
the Dark Matter Halos Drew gas into its
Center and created extremely massive
stars as we said before when A Star is
Born it blows away the gas cloud that
created it but these Titanic gas clouds
in the early Universe were so large and
massive that even after their birth more
and more gas piled on the newborn star
making it grow to unbelievable
proportions
the young star is forced to grow and
grow and grow getting more and more
massive until in some cases it reaches
up to 10 million times the mass of our
sun
crushed by gravity its core gets hotter
and hotter desperately pushing outwards
trying to blow itself apart but to no
avail
there's too much mass and too much
pressure the balance is impossible to
uphold
like a supernova run fast forward the
core gets crushed into a black hole
normally that would be the end today
stars go supernova a black hole forms
and things calm down but in this case
the star survives its own death
a tremendous explosion rocks the star
from the inside but it's not enough the
star is so large and massive but not
even a supernova can destroy it but now
it has a black hole for a heart
it's tiny a few tens of kilometers in
the center of a thing the size of the
solar system
the monster grows
Stars Are Born from ever fastest
spinning and collapsing gas and so they
also spin when a black hole is born from
the core of a star it keeps its angular
momentum this means that matter that
gets drawn in doesn't just fall in a
straight line but instead begins
orbiting the black hole in smaller and
smaller circles going faster and faster
the result is an accretion disc where
gas orbits at nearly the speed of light
only a small amount of gas actually
falls in at any given moment basically
black holes put a lot of food on the
table and only nibble at it but the
matter trapped in the accretion disk
doesn't have a good time friction and
collisions between particles heated up
to temperatures of millions of degrees
actively feeding black holes have
accretion discs that are incredibly hot
and Powerful
this heat from the disc further
restricts how much a black hole can
devour just like the core of stars the
super hot material creates radiation
that blows away most of the food within
its reach so even if a black hole had
access to as much food as it desired it
can only grow slowly
a black hole embedded inside a black
hole star is different the enormous
pressure surrounding it pushes down
matter directly into the black hole
overcoming all restrictions on how fast
it can consume
this process is so violent and releases
so much energy that the accretion disc
becomes hotter and releases more
radiation pressure than any star core
ever could
enough to push back against the weight
of 10 million Suns
an impossibly dangerous balance has been
created millions of sodomasses pushing
in the angry radiation of a force-fed
black hole pushing out
for the next few million years the black
hole star is consumed from within the
black hole grows to thousands of solar
masses and the bigger it gets the faster
it eats which heats up the star even
more and causes it to expand
in its Final Phase the black hole star
has become over 30 times wider than our
solar system truly the largest star to
ever exist in the universe
the intense magnetic fields at its core
spew out Jets of plasma from the black
hole's poles which Pierce through the
star and shoot out into space turning it
into a cosmic Beacon it must have been
one of the most or inducing sites to
ever exist in the universe
but this also marks the ant it becomes
too stretched and the accretion disc
within too powerful
the parasite destroys its host blowing
it apart
a black hole with the mass of one
hundred thousand suns reps its way out
to hunt for new prey while leaving
behind nothing but a star carcass
the supermassive question
if black hole Stars existed they could
explain one of the greatest Mysteries of
the universe
the supermassive black holes we see at
the center of galaxies are just too big
they shouldn't be possible
black holes born from regular supernovas
can be a few tens of solar masses at
most
and because of the process we explained
before they grow slowly after that if
black holes merge they can form slightly
larger black holes of over a hundred
solar masses
it should take billions and billions of
years to make black holes with hundreds
of thousands or even millions of solar
masses
and yet we know that some supermassive
black holes already had 800 million
solar masses only 690 million years
after the big bang
black hole stars are a sort of black
hole cheat code if they formed very
early in our universe and the black
holes that emerged from them were
thousands of solar masses then they
could be the seeds for supermassive
black holes
these seeds could take root in the
center of the earliest galaxies merging
with others and drawing in enough matter
to grow quickly and reliably
very soon we may be able to verify their
past existence the James Webb Space
Telescope is turning its senses to
explore the farthest reaches of the
universe looking back in time back to
the early universe that we couldn't see
before
so with luck we might be able to witness
glimpses of these tragic Titans in the
brief moment between their formation and
destruction
until then let's do the visual Journey
again just for fun
Stars a big black hole Stars bigger
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
project like the James Webb Space
Telescope requires some serious
budgeting but even personal finances are
a nightmare to manage on your own that's
why we want to introduce you to Rocket
money the sponsor of today's video just
as space exploration projects are
planned by professionals your finances
deserve professional attention too
rocket money is an all-in-one Finance
platform that helps with managing
expenses and saving money you can use it
to cancel unwanted subscriptions lower
your bills create budgets monitor your
credit score and create smart savings
accounts the feature we like best is
canceling subscriptions the platform
identifies recurring charges and helps
you cancel the ones you no longer want
no need to go through long hold times
with customer service you just click
cancel within the app you can also
upload screenshots of bills that you
want to lower and Rocket money will get
to work negotiating your bill for you
join the 3.4 million members using
rocket money to optimize their Finance
answers and download the app today you
can get access to features like
budgeting for free and unlock all
features with a premium subscription
rocket money makes it easier than ever
to spend less and save more basically
managing your money doesn't have to be
rocket science
we know you've been waiting for a long
time let's reveal the next limited
edition pin it's our universe to scale
about 10 to the power of minus 35
seconds after the big bang the
observable universe was only the size of
a marble before it expanded pre-order is
available for only 72 hours so you can
order it now and then never again
add it to your PIN collection or start a
new one
pin number three will be revealed soon
and as the year 12022 is slowly coming
to an end just kidding time flies by way
too fast will take a short break to
recharge our batteries thanks to all of
you out there for all the love and
support
We Wish You a peaceful and cozy turn of
the Year see you back at Full Throttle
in January
wait
[Music]
foreign
[Music]